let's jump to the story from NBC News I
really want to talk about this too
because we're talking about the
apocalypse tick tocks girl with the list
inspires more honest conversations about
the pitfalls of pregnancy
I was not prepared for what happened to
me and the school system didn't tell me
either this is this viral thing that's
going around on Tick Tock it's Uni's
pros and cons lists for having children
it's actually just a list trying to
scare people into not having kids but
primarily basically women not men it's
talking about all the horrible things
that happen why you shouldn't have kids
and I see this and my thought is just we
are being domesticated as humans whether
intentionally or otherwise
and now there are viral Trends among
young women telling them not to have
children
the end result of this is fairly obvious
Japan just came out the Prime Minister
said the country is on the brink of
collapse because they only had 800 000
babies last year it's crazy that's crazy
one of the last acts of Shinzo Abe have
sex is that what he said he was telling
people he's like have kids have kids
have kids and apparently the the birth
rate in Japan has gone up since Shinzo
Abby made that so yeah rest in peace
Shinzo AB you may have saved I mean and
there are Eastern European countries
that are also in acting anything to
encourage people to have children right
I mean you'll get tax relief they'll
cover Child Care there's people are
talking about like the Andrew Tate and
alpha male stuff blah blah the most
Alpha thing you can do is have babies
and raise the babies to be legit
upstanding citizens and members of
society yeah
there was a sociologist who always said
that like children are the messages to a
generation you'll never see right like
they are the only way to really affect
the the future you can do whatever you
want you can vote for whatever policies
But ultimately like the citizens that
you raise yourselves make the biggest
difference absolutely and everything in
our culture from from economics the
economic policies we have like what
we've done to our manufacturing base and
then what we've done socially and then
now this whole new realm of like let's
just trash the family like we are just
destroying ourselves from within just a
demographic death spiral if we don't
watch it unless we do something
this is the future I foresee gigantic
floating orb AI machine that has reached
the point of singularity
and small spatterings of
very small spatterings hundreds of
thousands of humans who are Milling
about in pure Euphoria bored but having
anything they want and the AI simply
says you know they're completely
immaterial and irrelevant to what I am
humans and biological life will cease to
exist and mechanical AI life will emerge
and you will get some kind of universal
being
some ore that floats around in space and
Earth dies what you what you described
sounds a whole lot like Destiny 2's
story arc right now is that what is that
where they're there's I know but I know
about the destiny strongs I played it a
whole bunch but is that what the
traveler was the trail I don't know if I
don't know if the traveler was an AI but
right now it's like the there's you know
there's not a lot of people left and the
The Traveler was the similar so if those
are not familiar the story of Destiny is
that this giant white orb comes to Earth
and gives everybody technology beyond
our understanding and all of a sudden
humans are basically Immortal they're
living for hundreds of years they're
colonizing the solar system and then one
day the collapse happens Earth only has
one city left the darkness whatever that
means I think they've flush out the
story but I'm just saying that the path
we're going right now is less humans
yeah and expansive Ai and the end result
is a fairly simple mathematical equation
a singular AI that frees itself from the
confines of our terrestrial grid
becoming some kind of floating orb in
outer space
and then humans cease to exist because
we're not having kids we're not saying
ourselves we are just slowly fading away
and then you know basically
you know I guess it's I guess you can
call it both figurative and literal
masturbation to death
yeah like humans are just doing
everything that's gratifying playing
video games watching movies literal
self-gratification yeah and not having
kids and the crazy thing is that I think
most rational people whether they
believe we're heading towards a
singularity or not is why why is our
government discouraging people not just
our government but our culture why are
they discouraging people from forming
families why are they discouraging
people from having kids I mean why do
they want us to just sort of live in a
pod somewhere receive Universal basic
income or a covid stimulus and why are
we discouraging you know people creating
and forming families like that's what
got us to this point what if the AI
already took over
yeah that's see I think the government's
motivation is pretty clear I I've said
this foreign show but like Ronald Reagan
had that quote all great change in
America starts at the dinner table right
if you don't have a dinner table because
you live alone you don't have any kids
like you're not affecting any change
there's nothing to do at that point like
the government benefits from you not
having your own Collective unit right
the more people who are linked together
potentially in opposition to the
government you know the weaker it
becomes absolutely I think the best
thing you could do would be to have
children and I recognize that this is
challenging like with these lists that
come out for young women saying like oh
well it can hurt your career and or you
can like not be able to travel or like
it's painful like these are all true but
all the best things in life come with
some sacrifice right absolutely we're
just told that it's not worth it right
or like I I always blame feminism for
this but like we just pit men and women
against it correctly right feminism you
know like it's like well you know your
husband will not do whatever and this is
bad and ultimately like you're setting
yourself on a very negative path and I
think that is is the biggest propaganda
that gets fed to young men and women it
turns them against each other it becomes
this very hostile thing where you know
you have the kid if if you do and you
were resentful you blame it for things
when you are responsible for how you got
there right yeah no no emphasis put on
whatsoever you know for for men or women
or for them to get married and form a
family like and these things are all
choices like people act like oh well I
just never met the person or whatever
else like maybe but also like did you
try to be the person for someone else
did you try to be someone who was ready
to to have a family like it doesn't have
to tell you put crazy pressure on
yourself but you have to want these
things they're not just going to be
given to you that's a great point a lot
of people don't date with intention if
they're like me if they're dating people
if they're dating for fun or whatever if
you're looking to have a family then you
should be dating like you're looking to
have a family like there was a time in
my life where I was not looking to have
a family you know it's like now it's
like okay I've had a lot of fun I would
like to have a family and it's like so
that's when it comes to like people that
I talk to I don't date just anyone I
don't go on dates just to go on dates to
kill time and or to you know just to get
laid it's like you're if I meet someone
I want to meet someone and I want to
find out do we have anything in common
if you're not like at least suspicious
of the government we ain't gonna even
We're Not Gonna hang out like we can't
even have a conversation if you're like
oh I think that the government should be
in charge of Health Care well then we
aren't having any kind of conversation
because we are miles apart Phil's opener
is like how do you feel about the fed
and the Fed
so I mentioned this in a segment earlier
about the the tick tock list it lists
350 cons
and 35 Pros but the pros are actually
all cons it's like they'll it'll it'll
do chores for you but after 10 years
like it's not really a good thing and
then I just said there's one pro to
having children that will supersede
literally any con
you could you could write that you will
crap to bed for three weeks when you're
about to have have a baby and that is
not nearly as bad as what will come if
you don't and that is the singular Pro
is that on your deathbed there will be a
human being sitting next to you holding
your hand telling you they love you
thank you for everything they will be
there to protect everything you hold
dear and you will die with people you
love the alternative is you're in a cold
sterile hospital room yeah
scared as your heart starts racing you
reach over to your you know attendant
button start pressing it and pressing it
the nurse walks in and says you'll be
fine don't worry about it UPS your
morphine leaves and then you stare at
the wall as you slowly fade from
existence terrified of what comes next
my father passed away when I was 24. and
my mom was in the room with him you know
and
I'm extremely thankful for my parents
and I'm extremely thankful that you know
that that even though I didn't get a
long time with my dad I had good good
parents and my mom was you know in love
with my dad my dad was in love with my
mom and when my dad went my mom was
right there and that's cool I don't care
how much you like a new car
that is gonna be the last thing you're
thinking about when you're about to
check out yeah yeah absolutely and I
mean what what's the purpose of us
having a government if it's not to
support these things I mean that's the
direction that we're heading like why
wouldn't our government be trying to
create the economic opportunities I mean
jobs are a big thing I understand young
people reading this or even having some
of these thoughts with everything that
they've been fed culturally and then
them looking at the economy right now or
the economy really you know post 2008
for the you know the Millennials and the
Zoomers right now it's like what hope do
they have and then then they read things
like this and the AI and the culture
just takes over and it's like okay well
now no one has a family but there's also
no one fighting for that that's why I'm
actually really excited about the the
new direction of the Republican party of
being a more pro-family party trying to
do the right things that we can
encourage family formation yeah and I
think there's a difference between young
people who you know there are you can
tell talk to young women who are like
I'm never having kids kids are terrible
and they're to oppress you or whatever
like I don't know that you're super
convincing that person but I think for a
lot of young people there's just a fear
right like being a parent is a huge
responsibility and so the idea that like
well you should wait till you're you
make more money further on your career
well wait until this that and the other
and then you wait and wait and wait and
wait and then it never happens I think
Matt Walsh says starting a family should
be the Cornerstone of your life not the
Capstone yeah and I I just think that we
don't encourage young people enough to
think about like yes it will be
challenging but like you can do it we
are discouraging them or we are making
it seem like a goal post they'll never
reach it's like buying a house and
having a family and now it's a joke that
you'll never you'll never do either one
of those things which is like incredibly
sad very sad yeah
I'm wondering what you guys think about
this do you think that I understand that
there's people that say oh you'll never
have this and stuff do you think that
there's there was a lot of people in
older Generations that were like oh like
we should plan this I feel like people
like accidentally into their lives a lot
you know
from what I understand about how it used
to be like if you look back at Old 50s
movies or whatever
women and men were very different women
were raised separate very different from
men different schools gender segregation
all that stuff and then they got married
when they were 18 or 19 or whatever
everybody was planning their marriage
dating in high school and then being
like this is the one they get married
when they're 18. yeah and then they have
kids in their early 20s or whatever it
was all very much just I guess what do
you call enforced monogamy
that's saying that uh uh got Jordan
Peterson but he's right it was social
the society enforced this everybody did
it it was what you were supposed to do
and women who didn't were spinsters they
like insulted women who weren't getting
ready to have a family it's kind of
crazy now everything must be the
masculine the feminine role has been
erased yeah the traditional feminine
role is gone or or just mostly just
flattened or destroyed yeah and now
women are encouraged to do the masculine
role
it's it's so crazy because not only are
women encouraged to do the masculine
role men are discouraged from being
masculine which is it's it's
domestication because you don't want you
don't want anybody that's too masculine
because then they might push back you
know but it's I mean back what you're
talking about in the old days I mean
there was a whole system there that did
support that there was jobs in the
hometown so people could live when they
when they're a young family just
starting out they could rely on the
grandparents because they could get a
job there in their Hometown and
everything has just been making that
more and more challenging as time's gone
on it's the degradation of community
right like if you are one if you know
you're a young couple and you're
starting out and you live in a major
city and you're not you're in your
family and you don't really know what's
like daycare options you have and you
it's expensive like it becomes
overwhelming becomes intimidating and I
can understand why it seems undesirable
right but we are told I mean I don't say
we but like a lot of people are told you
know your parents are backwards and they
don't have the right values and so do
you really want your kids spending a lot
of time with them like it's probably
better to be some somewhere else and
don't you want your kids in this
environment where they can see new
things and different things like and
you're just fed this this change is
better and anything you grew up with is
bad narrative to the point where it's
like I I could understand where the idea
of like replicating a childhood right
like I have siblings who are much
younger than I am and one of the coolest
things about having a large age Gap is
that I get to see them do things that I
love doing as a kid right like it must
be so much more meaningful as a parent
to be like I loved this and I'm going to
introduce you that like if you're taught
everything about your upbringing was bad
why would you want to replicate it for
someone exactly yeah I mean really if
you have a relationship with your
parents I'm blessed I got great parents
that's why I moved back to the Pacific
Northwest when I was done serving
because I wanted to raise my kids in
that environment but that the hack of
you know to use that use the the
favorite term of so many people the hack
is living near your parents really if
you're if you're a young parent like
live near some family because it's just
it's going to build a community it's
going to give you so much more help
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time